work on your independent research
project but because we do have a lot of
people that are new to this
i want to start off by just kind of
briefly and i will try to really
keep it short but kind of go over the
major
parts of the program how it is organized
and then
i will pass it on to somalia and uh dr
harpridka or
to guide the session for today's
presentations
so let me start by kind of introducing
you to
our background who we are so uh
as you all know omixlogic is a
bioinformatics training portal
that has been developed by this
collaboration that we have between pine
biotech
and the talbot bioinformatics research
center which is a research center
at the university of haifa but over the
years we have
had the chance to work with students
researchers and
clinicians from many different
institutions from around the world
and as a result we now have this global
community
that has over 10 000 participants from
all around the world
and we have gone through many steps of
iteration to
make sure that our program is structured
and well prepared for the needs of those
that are interested
in bioinformatics and data science in
application to a variety of different
biological and biomedical challenges
so we have a dedicated team in india
we also have a number of pilots that we
have done at different universities
and our background is that we have done
a lot of in-person workshops as well as
different types of online programs that
we've conducted
uh in the past couple of years we also
have a dedicated
team in africa that is uh spearheaded by
our team in nigeria and we also have a
number of
other participants from other different
countries
and we have been trying to work with the
local
and regional partners that we have to
make sure that
our content and materials are well
adapted to the needs
of these local participants and so we
think that we've gotten very positive
feedback
and we've conducted these again in india
in africa and obviously also in the us
so in the us our major partner is the
louisiana biomedical research
network but also georgetown university
and others and so what this allows us to
do
is to really bring you the best
materials from all of these locations
consolidated and adapted to an online
experience
leveraging our experience offline and
kind of trying to facilitate this
process of research and discovery
using bioinformatics and so the outcome
that we see
as a result of this kind of training
is the ability to guide
and help complete research projects
conducted by faculty teams of people
as well as individuals so the research
fellowship
combines access to big data
which means big data resources
as well as tools to analyze and process
big data
mentorship which is both experts
trainers and peer example as well as
access to a variety of training
resources for asynchronous and live
training and so what we are trying to
address here
is the problem of helping people
access resources for big data analysis
mentors that can help match the right
kind of analysis methods
to their research question and a
community that will keep you accountable
and provide you with feedback
so that you are prepared to work on
impactful topics
and develop your research projects until
the very end when you are ready to
present
and so this comes with a lot of program
resources that we've developed that we
think could be very helpful for all of
you now we tried to combine
all of these resources on our onyx logic
training portal that has a variety of
different types of
asynchronous courses as well as
more guided programs that are led by
experts in bioinformatics and we provide
for all of the participants of this
program
access to specific sessions that you can
access
to understand whether that program is
right for you
and this is typically done in
collaboration with other universities
and organizations
so not only do you get the opportunity
to learn about the topic but also
interact from particip with participants
from these different institutions
but you can find all of this on our onyx
logic portal which is
learn that omixlogic.com you will find
there
adapted courses for you personally based
on your experience
as you progress that will change you
will be able to
track your progress and see how you've
improved your understanding of the basic
topics
as well as the application of these
different tools
in different types of challenges and
projects like this is an example of a
project on the origin and pathogenesis
of the novel coronavirus and we have
many other examples like that as well
so behind this what we also provide is
access
to user-friendly big data analysis tools
and this
is a critical component of this program
you get access to
five terabytes of storage which allows
you to process and
analyze large data sets that allow you
to use
advanced statistical methods and machine
learning
as well as multi-omics integration and
several tools that will be helpful for
biological interpretation now this
infrastructure is limited we do not give
everybody access to that same resource
and the research fellows that have
joined this program have
that kind of a special level of access
where you can actually conduct a full
research project
but you have to coordinate it with us
and so what that allows you to do
is to explore a data set and find
the right methods to apply to
a research question so the objective of
this research fellowship
that i will briefly discuss today is to
start from training
and then guide you to complete some of
the training resources that i've
identified
create a sense of understanding and
practical skills and then to apply that
to a number of research
problems now the best way to get started
is to really take a look
at a variety of projects that we already
have available
and these range from topics in
biomedical
applications to biotechnology to a
variety of human health related topics
as well as more advanced topics in
cancer
biotechnology agriculture
neurodegeneration
if infectious diseases and ultimately
any other topic that you would like to
focus on
but it's important to come to that topic
prepared to really be able to understand
how
experts work on projects to understand
how to find data sets
to specifically identify a research
question and then find the right tools
and so
the research fellowship is really an in
silico
research experience where you have three
to six months typically
some of you i know have joined for only
two months but typically is going to be
from
three to six months and you're able to
work
as a part of a structured program and
today's session in
is one of these examples where you
hopefully come away with a clear
understanding of what
the program does and how it's organized
so that you can navigate the different
resources
with ease so a critical point of that
is this structure that we've developed
that is divided up into three parts
first there's the introduction where you
get the introduction to bioinformatics
theory methodology and applications
you get to use some of the cloud tools
for big data processing
and also complete some of the
introductory coursework
then it's the evaluation where you start
to
analyze literature from other
publications and
other data sets to understand how to
develop a research proposal
and then one once you have done that you
can apply the
tools that you've learned how to use to
a problem of your own
to help guide you through that process
we have two
specific channels that help us help you
one of those is our slack channel so at
this point
can i ask everyone that's present today
how many of you that are
actually a part of the research
fellowship have joined the slack channel
okay if you have joined the slack
channel please put in the chat
yes or one or something like that okay
thank you all right excellent
okay thank you everyone so if you have
not gotten
access to the slack channel i see
nandita aishwarya
if you have already applied for the
research fellowship and received your
acceptance letter
you should be added to the slack channel
so please reach out
to marketing at pine bio and somalica
who is here today with us will be able
to add you there
the second important part and so malika
maybe you could
uh be in contact with the people that
said no make sure that
if they have applied and uh gotten their
access they should be a part of that
okay so i would want to add here that i
have sent you all the
invitation already for the slack channel
please check your
mail ids and then you will get your
invitation there and then you can join
i'll send it out again
thank you thank you
and the second one is this weekly
progress report form
so once you are a part of the research
fellowship and you would like to discuss
any updates technical challenges or
questions that you might
have before a weekly session you have to
submit the weekly progress report form
okay so i've seen a few of you have
submitted that form today
typically you would want to submit that
form
a few days before the session so that
our team can prepare
and address the specific questions that
you have
or if you have a presentation that you
want to share your progress report with
us
we can help you address any kind of like
immediate questions and so
i will talk a little bit about the
presentation here in just a second as
well
the second part is access to these
publicly available data sets so when you
collect
raw data for your uh project
uh you have to be familiar with what
this data represents
okay so a big mistake that many people
make is the first data set that they
come across they start working on that
data set
before you start analyzing anything the
reason why we ask you to submit this
progress report is that we want to know
that you
are trained and ready to analyze a
particular type of data
and also that you have explored the data
metadata
so how do you explore the metadata
typically that means
you have to read the paper and in the
paper you will find that associated data
set but
in the paper they also describe how did
they generate the data set
why did they generate it what were the
questions that they were asking
and that typically results in a specific
design
that helps you extract from there the
types of comparisons and contrast that
you would be able to do
in your own research project so
typically you also have to
perform exploratory data analysis so
that you can
understand the variability in the data
set
and oftentimes people will end up using
multiple data sets so you have to be
familiar with methods to normalize your
data
explore your data address any kind of
technical variation and only then ask
that specific question so hopefully the
tools that we provide
will be sufficient for you to be able to
do that quickly
now after that after that not before
that but after that
you choose a topic right and in that
topic
you want to be very specific and find a
topic that is compelling and
interesting to the audience that you
will present right so
you have to have the data set available
you have to understand what is the
background
and then you also have to do literature
review to understand
where is that specific topic that you
would like to
focus on for the next three to six
months if you do that
before you've explored the data before
you've write the literature
you're not going to be able to find an
impactful topic that you can actually
work on
so here we provide specific training and
i'm not going to do this today but
you've probably seen this in previous
sessions and if you have not
you can request that recording or you
can also
join one of our upcoming sessions where
we will do this kind of training where
we go through how to perform literature
review
how to identify a specific topic of
interest
how to ask a research question and
ultimately how to
translate that into a particular
question or hypothesis that you can work
on and that's where your mentor really
comes in
so as a result of analyzing your
activity
on the onyx logic portal and as a result
of
looking at the specific coursework that
you have completed
the articles that you have submitted in
the research proposal
and other things our mentor will be able
to use that time
effectively so we don't want to use the
mentor time for just going through the
very basics how to open excel how to
install r
how to find the data set things like
that that's where
these weekly meetings are for the mentor
session is to help you address the
specific question that you might have
and make it more impactful and so for
that
we've developed this step-by-step
process
where you identify a topic you find a
data set
you make a table of metadata and you
explore your data
and then when you conduct your analysis
you put all of that into a shared
presentation and that presentation
should be shared with your mentor
that presentation is where we can find
all of the updates that you're making
and see how you're making progress so
that we can help get you unstuck
in technical issues and also point your
attention
on the most interesting aspects of your
data set
when you present to the mentor you're
not only presenting to the mentor you're
also presenting to the peer community
that is all a part of this research
fellowship so today we will hear
a number of these project presentations
we will give
feedback but also we ask that you ask
questions
you pay attention to the presentation
and you think about
how is this project addressing the
specific need
or question that was proposed at the
beginning of that question right so that
process of information exchange and
participation is also a critical part of
this program
once you incorporate all that feedback
then you can finalize the presentation
and potentially identify a poster
presentation
or a research journal for peer review
that you would like to submit
and that's something that we will talk
about today how to make your
presentation
impactful and organized so that it
is making sense and it is effective
at conveying the story when you process
the data for analysis
it's important to understand that some
of these data sets are huge
and when you go through these data sets
you have to follow a specific
process and so that's where the training
is very important
but beyond getting the basic data set
organized and prepared you then have to
be able to explore the data and that's
why we also provide you with training
on how to use basic tools like excel
r python and different online tools that
you can leverage
to explore the data set that you have
selected and make sense of it so please
leverage some of the
tutorials that we have on the
learnomicslogic.com portal
and that will help you deal with that
data set
once you perform the in-depth analysis
we have several
experts that can help in a variety of
different topics
for transcriptomic data for structural
data for genomic data
for different parts we can match you
with somebody that can help
answer your specific questions you have
to let us know so remember that
it's your responsibility to reach out to
us and let us know
what is it that you're interested in
doing and how we can best help you
finally when you get to this process of
preparing your analysis results
you are going to be also following
examples of many others that have gone
through the same process
and so that's where your peer community
is going to be very helpful
so when you present and you go through
these iterations
of drafts you will see that we can help
you the most by making that presentation
better
and helping you present something to
external evaluators
at poster presentations if you're
looking to submit a research article
in a much more prepared way and so the
outcomes
of this process are very important to
keep in mind right so have a goal when
you're joining this program have a
specific goal
you will have a guarantee and a positive
outcome
if you properly identify what that
outcome for you is
maybe you just want to understand the
specific challenges and data sets and
gain training
that's one option maybe you want to
develop some skills like processing data
and analyzing data maybe you want to
join an independent project or a group
project so that's another option you
don't have to work on this on your own
we will hear today from root v who has
completed an independent project and
hopefully she will continue to work on a
group project next so
some people will actually announce that
i'm working on this topic and i'm
looking for collaborators
that's why it's important to be a part
of the slack channel in our community
so that everybody can get to know each
other not only hear their presentations
and the final results
so let me briefly tell you what are some
of the recent examples of people that
have successfully completed the research
projects and the research fellowship
april zhang uh
just recently completed a research
fellowship
she's a high school student and now she
got accepted to
berkeley for bioinformatics
undergraduate
and we have a recording of her
presentation that you can take a look at
i'm gonna post
uh the link right here
see my dollar she will be presenting in
the next
uh core in the next psionics
session that will happen i believe
tomorrow but i will let
rudy talk about that in a little bit uh
supantha who is from bangladesh
and he is also you can see his project
presentation he will also be presenting
at the cyanomix club
dr anita gansa who is right now working
still
on a number of research projects
together with
her team and we have collaborated with
her and her
team to recently present her project at
the
louisiana biomedical research network so
please take a look at some of these
links and you'll kind of see
how this works for some of the other
people that you might
be following in their footsteps and all
of them
are of course going to be available as
somebody that can give you
hints and tips and maybe some guidance
on how to complete a project and make it
impactful
so that's an important part of the
outcome as well when you think of
completing this project think about how
are you going to use it to also advance
your personal career and learning
and so we have an example of urja that
finished her
project a while back andres who has
completed his project and will be
presenting next week
we have others that are uh selected to
be a part of this program and so
please do share that information with
others with your network
to help them understand what you are
working on
so now let me pass this on to uh dr
harpreed or sonalik i don't know who
is going to announce who is going to be
presenting next
so that you can kind of see where this
process
will lead you as you join this research
fellowship
thank you so much elia i would uh want
our new research fellows to
introduce themselves before we start the
presentations
so uh are not can you please introduce
yourself we have arnold jean with
us today he has just joined our program
are not over to you please
yes um hi thank you sonalika um
so um i'm i'm jean on odd as you see in
the picture except the names backwards
um coming from originally from haiti in
the caribbean
but now in massachusetts um
and uh i have um i was trained as a
chemist
but um and i worked in biomedical
science um at a institution next to
mit um and i uh but while working there
i realized
i was mostly focused on um metabolomics
um so small metabolites that
biomarkers for diseases um and
but one thing that became very evident
is that there's a
so here i am working with the lcms and
and other mass spectrometry
instruments and it became very evident
that
uh a lot of biomedical research is
actually systems biology
and uh and i had no training and uh
in r or python or
or metagenomics and so i uh i looked for
opportunity to um
to develop some skills and i did find a
few a few training
opportunities but uh um i always
felt as though it was not well or as
well organized
as i would like um so when i discovered
this program
um and i had the chance to talk to ilya
brodsky
um i i one thing i said was that
amazing you guys are actually giving me
the logic
of all of these tidbits and so um and so
i signed up recently and i'm looking
forward to
uh to learning more last thing i'll say
is my particular interest as of right
now
for as a topic um is long covid
i have a few a friend of mine who who um
who uh who had kovid recovered
but there's there's continuing symptoms
after you've had covid and that is
referred to as long covic
and so i'm very much interested into
some of the
bioinformatics associated with that
thank you
it was great to know about you uh john
or not that's how you spell your name
okay and now i would want tanmay to
introduce himself please tanmay
thank you so much and thank you so much
i know
i'm i'm really fascinated by the kind of
research that you're into
so my name is tanya arora as you can
probably see on your streams right now
and i'm currently working as a
researcher at
different labs on and on a few different
r d projects
so i'm currently working at the indian
institute of technology in gandhi nagar
and i'm also working at iit delhi and
the defense research and development
organization
in new delhi and uh one of the things
that uh
that have always fascinated me is the
integration between computers and cells
so if you think about it computers and
cells are essentially
the same at the most fundamental level
they're both really
complex machines and they happen to
share very same
very similar concepts of signals
networks
pathways and even memory so it was this
uh it was this curiosity the words
computers and cells that really got me
into research in the first place
and over the course of the past five
years i've employed all of my time and
my resources towards
the large goal of deconvoluting the very
wiring itself
and slowly trying to understand how life
in itself is digital
in nature and i believe that's really
the primary goal that we
uh which we're looking for uh out here
at
fine biotech and in addition to that uh
i'm currently working on the topic of
nano optogenetics
so the project that i'm working at uh at
iit gandhi nagar it's
centralized around the very viability of
incorporating
different stimulus responsive proteins
in optogenetics
and the potential benefits and
challenges of this novel focal
stimulation approach
uh inside of the whole entire process of
nano optogenetics
so that's about me
thank you so much sanme now uh we'll
take up the other introductions maybe
after this presentation so now i'm going
to hand over
the stage to ruthvi who would be
presenting on a project ruthie has
already completed her project
so let's see uh what she has done
through how to project
and learn more about it over to you
yes can you see my screen ah yes we can
see
okay hello everyone i am rudy and i did
this
internship with pine biotech and i
worked on the topic of multiple
sclerosis
i was very fascinated by this topic and
the kind of different characteristics it
shows like
lesions and everything we will look
ahead of so the reason for choosing this
topic was this one
so i'm an undergraduate third year
student of biomedical sciences and i'm
from india gujarat
my interests particularly are
neuroscience cancer neurobiology and
bioinformatics
precisely neuroinformatics i've worked
on dipg
multiple sclerosis for this project and
autism and immunology
so before diving it into the project i
would like to brief you all about what
actually multiple sclerosis is
so it is a central nervous system
disorder mainly a white matter diseases
which is a neurodegenerative diseases
and characterized
and it is characterized by the
demyelination of the
myelin sheath in the axons because of
demyelination
the patients of multiple sclerosis
suffer an acute episode of neurological
disturbances
and also due to this demyelination the
balance
between the brain and the body that is
the normal rhythm also gets disrupted
so usually multiple sclerosis till now
has been regarded as a white matter
diseases but since
last five years there has been extensive
research that shows that
not only white matter but multiple
sclerosis also affects the gray matter
still the underlying causes of it have
to yet to be unfolded
so talking about the morphology of
multiple sclerosis
the pathology is characterized by the
multiple focal lesions
and the ms plaques that develops in
white matter as well as gray matter
areas of the cortical regions of the
brain so till now scientists have found
out that
t cells that is activated t cells in the
lymph nodes
enter the cns through blood brain
barrier and then they start attacking
the myelin sheath of the exon due to
which demyelination
happens but in the first place there has
been no research
till date which shows that why these t
cells or say b cells get activated and
attack
the myelin sheath so talking about my
research question and hypothesis
so my main research question was that
patients
of multiple sclerosis have
less or deemed cognitive functions and
they usually tend to forget
things and cannot pay attention to any
particular thing so memory loss is one
of the
most important characteristics of ms
also
so using this main research question i
wanted to answer my hypotheses that were
three divided as first
i wanted to know the biological pathways
and the respective functions that were
affected in patients
that had gray matter lesions that is ms
patients
i also wanted to find out that does
multiple sclerosis precisely have
effect over the development or
differentiation of protein
cells because you will see ahead that i
had
gene ontology results presenting
hematopoietic stem cell lineage pathways
as well and i also wanted to know that
are there any specific genes
in multiple sclerotic lesions that they
are up regulated or down regulated
and any specific role with any
biological
pathway that they play or not in
multiple sclerosis
so owing to this hypothesis i started my
i started searching my data set so this
was the data set that i
found and it consists of tissue samples
of cortical tissues
and it had total 184 samples in totals
out of which this is a super series so i
took only one subseries
that had 78 samples which had gray
matter
lesions versus control gray matter so
this
is a slide depicting my study
methodology so firstly what i did was
add in a sequencing analysis so i had
three types of
uh sub data sets like the sub data
experimental groups
the first one was the gray matter
lesions the second one was normal
appearing gray matter and the third were
controls
so firstly i wanted to explore all the
conditions by comparing it them with
each other so first i did my exploratory
analysis
in which i compared all the three of the
groups with each other by doing a t-test
under all conditions that is all three
later on i compared each
two of them with each other that is
lesions with normal appearing gray
matter
by normal appearing gray matter i mean
that that person has multiple sclerosis
but do not have lesions
so i compared lesions with normal
appearing gray matter by bca
and also compared controls with normal
appearing gray matter
the variation i saw was good in both but
the most variation i could see was among
control
and gray matter lesions which we will
see further so i downstream my analysis
and then went for comparative analysis
between gray matter lesions and control
gramata
for differential gene expression i used
hr
and after getting up regulated and down
regulated and significant genes i did
gene selection with a
top 700 genes that i got and further on
i did pathway analysis
again i did visualization by pca and
then heat map for all the significant
genes that i had extracted out
and later on when i got my results i did
literature review in order to compare my
results with previous studies and get
conclusions
and derive conclusions from them so
talking about my exploratory analysis so
this was the first pc i did
on my left hand side you can see the pca
between normal appearing gray matter and
gray matter lesions
and on the right hand side you can see
controls and gray matter lesions
so you can see that the after
downstreaming my analysis
the variation among this that is healthy
and gray metallization was very well so
i took forward
my downstream analysis with this part of
the data set
this is a slide depicting the heat map
with significant genes
so i had selected significant genes with
p value less than or equal to
0.05 so in this heat map it can be
clearly seen that most of the
significant genes
are down regulated in the lesions
whereas
adam regulated in the control samples
whereas most of them are upregulated in
gray matter lesions which showed a clear
indication that in lesions
something is up regulated which leads
the formation of inflammation or rather
say
lesions so after selecting upregulated
and downregulated genes and my
significant genes i did pathway analysis
using the human gauge pipeline on t by
info server so the top two heat pathways
that i got was first is olfactory
transduction pathway and second i got
was hematopoietic stem cell lineage
pathway
so for olfactory transduction pathway
the r1 you can see over here that is the
oil factory receptor r protein which is
responsible for sensing the odor
and smell detectant pathways was highly
upregulated
was highly upregulated in grey metal
lesions
so i'm sorry down regulator in gray
matter lesions due to which it was a
possible association that people
who are detected with multiple sclerosis
have
a lowered sense of smelling and odor
detection
the second pathway that i got was
hematopoietic stem cell lineages
and it could be seen that among the
whole picture of this pathway
interleukin-3 is highly downregulated
so over here association can be made
that
is down regulation of interleukin-3 a
possible reason for t
cells attacking the myelin sheath or
under developed bone marrow a possible
cause of multiple sclerosis onset
so after this pathway analysis i did the
pathway analysis with
enricher with particular down regulated
genes so in down regulated genes you can
see that the top hits were all olfactory
receptor activities and
perception of smell pathways which
clearly indicated that this pathway was
disturbed in the
patients of multiple sclerosis further i
did pathway analysis with upregulated
genes which showed
top hit in ribosomal protein synthesis
and oxidative phosphorylation
which were also the results i got on
human gauge t
bio info platform server pipeline
so after that i had to make associations
so the possible association i could make
was the down regulation of oil factory
receptor proteins and multiple sclerosis
so what i did was out of the significant
genes expressed i picked out the genes
which were responsible for
the oil faction that is or genes and i
plotted a bulk plot comparing it with
gml lesions and control gray matter
so in the bad plot it is quite evident
that in lesions these genes are down
regulated
and as compared to the control so these
were the top 12 genes again this was my
hypothesis
so i needed my validation to be
concluded in order to prove that my
findings are true
which would come ahead in the next
slides so after that i
also found that protein kinase a which
was severally related to my studies
so protein kinase a generally functions
in cognitive functioning like
inactivation of brain reward system
or in preservance of short-term and
long-term memory so as per our keg
analysis pka protein in the order
detection pathway
is highly down regulated in multiple
sclerosis patients which had
lesions so we can also make a possible
association i
i'm not saying that i'm quite sure but
over here i'm talking about an
association
between pka and the loss of cognitive
functions
or the memory loss in patients of
multiple sclerosis
because over here in the picture it is
quite clearly visible that
protein sinus a is present in nucleus
acumens
and protein kinase is directly activated
by
dopamine receptors which are responsible
for producing dopamine
a loss of dopamine is also an important
characteristics in patients of multiple
sclerosis
and hence a possible relation can be
made between
pka protein and memory loss and multiple
sclerosis
moving to the analysis of hematopoietic
stem cell lineage pathways there were
three or four possible questions
and associations i could possibly make
so still more research is needed in
future to assess the precise effects of
multiple sclerosis on differentiation of
proteases
but however down regulation of
interleukin in the whole hematopoietic
stem cell lineage pathway
shows that thrombocytopenia
which are often the main characteristics
of patients of ms relation
so talking about the hypothesis that is
the top 12 olfactory genes that we found
that were down regulated in gml patients
that is
ms patients i took another data set that
106 samples
so 106 samples were divided into
cortical normal appearing gray matter
versus control gray matter
so again this was a brain cortical
tissue gray matter tissue
sample of and i use this is a different
data set and i use this for validation
so to my excitement for the validation
there were also other olfactory genes
that were down regulated by
but i extracted the 12 genes that were
there in my hypothesis and compared it
to the controls and
in validation i exactly got the same
results that is these genes were
as well down regulated in multiple
sclerosis patients
without lesions as well so hence it was
pretty sure
that olfactory dysfunction and oil
factory disruption pathway is seen in
patients of multiple sclerosis
also for a better picture i have plotted
a box plot representing the down
regulation
of genes in normal appearing gray matter
the olfactory genes
and they are normally expressed in
healthy controls
so my key findings and suggestions
include the top 12 olfactory genes which
were shown to be down regulated in
multiple sclerotic
possible association between protein
kindness a
cognitive loss of functions and compared
to multiple sclerosis
also as per from our analysis a possible
association can be made between
suppressed
production of interleukin-3 and
thrombocytopenia and multiple sclerosis
for my future interjections i would
state that much research is needed in
this area to assess the precise effect
of multiple sclerosis and protein cells
differentiation and development
also more comprehensive research is
needed to support my findings
and i am done with my presentation thank
you so much
thank you so much for sharing with us
your research work and it's really great
now i would want our mentors to please
provide the reviews and the suggestions
to ruthie
i mean i just want to say that rudy it's
very exciting to see your
presentation uh kind of coming together
if you could please go back to your
first slide just so that we have
something
in front of us so i think that you know
it's very interesting
how you went through this project
and kind of developed your hypothesis
to then finding the specific signal
then focusing on validation and
you ended up with multiple questions at
the end that i think
do require further research so i really
like the way that you structured the
presentation
and i'm hoping that you know as you move
forward i know that you still have some
time left
that you will find an opportunity to
collaborate with
other people on addressing some of these
questions perhaps or if you have some
you know kind of further
questions that appear that you would
like to focus on so
uh could you speak a little bit about
how this process
worked for you you know how long did it
take when did you kind of
click clearly identify that specific
question that you had in mind
like what was that like for you okay so
to be honest i started in middle of
february
and i am a biomedical sciences student
with a zero experience in bioinformatics
and i'm not at all ashamed to say this
that i did not even know that what nc by
ncbi stands for or is there even a
website
named ncbi so firstly i had to do all
these courses
and after doing courses i didn't even
know what data sets
meant so i had to had few sessions with
herpet ma'am so she
taught me about how to find a data set
how to extract that so everything and
finding a correct data set took me
two months to be honest finding it on my
own
but after that doing pca differential
gene expression i obviously had
technological and technical problems as
well
but you know when you learn on your own
after doing a thing you
text your teachers and they give you a
time but you cannot wait in between for
the specific
amount of time so you start reviewing
articles or searching on youtube
the videos that the institution has
uploaded in order to solve your query on
your own
so one thing i learned in this project
is to overcome difficulties
on our own and then going to the mentors
because
mentors have really an expertise way of
selling them and after talking to my
mentors everything seemed
so easy i i remember in february there
was a time when i didn't know anything
and i had to
you know exactly ask my mentors what
should i do what is pc and everything
but after four months now i am helping
my fellow colleagues and
the persons who are working with me so
it has been an incredible curvy journey
but i have definitely learned a lot
from this
all right great thank you very much i
think that's a great perspective so
thank you for sharing again i know it's
been a long journey and
really excited to see the results sure
thank you
doctor would you like to ask yeah hi
and it is very nice presentation and i
am really happy to see your progress
and i have just few questions and maybe
you just need to or maybe you need to
correct them
so first question regarding your uh
where you are identifying significant
change if i do remember we have not
taken p
value that is p adjusted value and as
well
you can also consider log to full chains
and please uh i mean correct that
on your slide so another another thing
that is when you are working on
significant genes i mean especially on
the validation data
and you are drawing bad plot i think uh
in uh in comparison to the wire plot it
even it's much better maybe heat map so
and another thing can you just go to the
your last slide second last slide where
you're trying to show the results
i mean box store type
this one yeah i think it is uh somehow
maybe you just need to
replot it it is not clear so i can show
you like how you can do it in
our so yeah this is something that you
need to
i mean sure i'll make this corrections
and let you know
okay okay thank you thank you
thank you thank you so much dr harpreet
for your reviews
now i would like to invite asma to share
her presentation over to you esma
thank you i'm making you the co-host you
can share your screen
there okay
uh yes please go ahead yeah
can you see it's not uh yes we can see
okay welcome to my review session i am
ice matalgun
from turkey billiken university uh my
research interests are
epigenetics immunology and autoimmune
diseases
i completed three courses genomics
transcriptomics and epigenetics one two
and three
i select the disease which is called
rheumatoid arthritis
it's an autoimmune disease it can
develop at any age and it can affect
a woman more than men and
many genetic and environmental factors
are appeared to be involved in this
disease
and when we look at its treatments
disease modifying
anti-rheumatic drugs are used this
disease has some
stages which are early moderate severe
and end stage
also there is a stage called remission
and it's
the total absence of symptoms
i select these data sets to further
analysis
uh this is an rna-seq study of snow
wheel biopsies it's an expression
profiling by
high throughput sequencing i look at the
disease states in these data sets which
i'm interested in especially normal
health healthy people uh established
through madrid artists
patients and earlier matrix at artist
patients
what did i do from now on i select my
data sets i
did principal component analysis then i
used this eq for differential gene
expression analysis
and then i did enrich our
analysis to look at the gene ontology
and cake pathways
and i want to show them to you today
and these are my desec analysis results
this is for the early and established
rheumatoid artist patients
when i look at the pathways the nicotine
addiction
draw my attention because i know that
smoking increases the risk of
rheumatoid arthritis disease and also
some other
pathways are important and i look at
this
goal biological process functions etc
and this is for the normal and early
romantic artist patients
and these are my results actually i want
to
ask what should i do for the next step
when i look at looking at these results
okay so i mean here you have just like
performed and listen now you need to
explore like what are these pathways
right
so i mean you need to do
no analysis on this like body how these
pathway biologically affected with the
rheumatoid arthritis
so and another thing can you just go
back to
your previous slide yeah
like yeah i mean how many upregulated
and how many down regulated genes that
you have identified i mean
you should consider those things
whenever you're presenting your work
like maybe in terms of tables or
something like
and then now you most important thing
you need to analyze like which pathway
so how they biologically
uh i mean affected this arthritis you
know arthritis disease
so you need to i mean no you need to
correlate these
things maybe with the literature as well
and you need to understand how these
pathway actually affect the disease
right
so that is something that you need to
explore yeah
okay then i will look at them
and because how many you need to
identify and and also need to mention
how many genes that you have identified
here
yeah i forgot to write it sorry
yeah i mean you need to explore these
kind of things
so yeah and uh i would like to ask to
ilya
to add i mean suggestion
yeah thank you so i think that you know
you are
starting to put together this project
and you got to a point where you find
these differentially expressed genes
the differential expression is supposed
to tell you
what are the biological differences and
one of the challenges
is to take many different sets of genes
that are grouped together by pathway
like you're showing here
and to make sense of how this is
interconnected
so as you've seen rootly she has used an
explanation of what the pathway is
overall
to show us how different genes are
influenced
by this condition she also wanted to get
at the end to a set of genes that she
could validate right
and so i think in your project it is a
little bit of a similar approach
you describe the problem statement you
then
define basically when you're doing
differential gene expression is you know
that's the contrast that you've selected
to do
and so even before that i would add some
slides
on pca or kind of a summary statistical
summary
of what it is that you found overall in
your project
actually i was editing but i as i have a
limited time
i skip them yeah this is fine but this
is an important actually part of your
presentation because maybe uh
you know here we see technical outliers
rather than yeah maybe you've addressed
that right so
that process of defining what the data
set looks like
to be able to ask the differential
expression kind of a
test right is something that you want to
present to us as well
and then when you finalize your
gene expression analysis you know
show us what do you think the
you know jeans mean okay so maybe in
your slide 22 i don't know what what is
slide 22
this one so like here
you know you um it seems like you have
a very significant uh difference
and that is typically defined by these
parameters the adjusted p value
the log flow change and so you can
modify them
to focus on you know significantly
expressed as well as significantly
differentiated
maybe making sure that you're selecting
the right kinds of genes for downstream
analysis
and so what i would say is that at this
stage
your presentation is a good time to
schedule a one-on-one meeting
with dr harpreet to kind of discuss more
in depth
what are all of the findings to sort
through them
and focus on some specific patterns that
you were finding
okay thank you very much
thank you so much as uh esma now i would
want to invite roof to
present his project over to you through
thank you true it would be great if you
introduce yourself to before you start
your presentation
uh is my screen visible yes it's visible
so hello everyone my name is romero and
i'm a bachelor of science honors in
medical biotechnology
so last year i graduated from american
olympia
and at present i'm working as a research
fellow at fine biotic
and talking about my past experiences
i've worked as an intern
in research and sangha department of a
precision medicine company so
there i used to work with my team on
projects related to genomics
so it all revolved around ngs and dna
sequencing
other than that i worked as an
histopathology intern
at a government hospital here in new
delhi
so talking about my research interests
so my research interest
revolves around precision medicine
cancer biology
genomics and conceptomics and through
this fellowship i'm actually
you know developing an understanding of
data science as well
so today i'll be uh presenting my
progress of research my research project
called
transcriptomic analysis of respiratory
carcinoma
uh so i'll just uh quickly give a very
a brief introduction so isotherms uh
esophagus is actually a muscular organ
that can increase the
stomach uh esophageal carcinoma is a
malignant
neoplasm of esophagus uh so it has two
predominant
histological type called the esophageal
pharmaceutical carcinoma
and esophageal adenocarcinoma so this
disease is actually uh you know
associated with tobacco use alcohol
consumption
and a deficiency of vitamin a b 3 and c
along with that the disease is actually
you know related to
various health conditions such as
esophagitis
celiac disease and
so talking about the epidemiology so
these figures are actually from the
who global cancer repository so
these are figures from the 2020 uh
data so talking about the esophageal
carcinoma
uh there were more than six hundred
thousand cases of
esophageal cancers and the resulting
mortality
were like more than 540 000
so these figures are quite high and you
know it indicates
the need of new therapeutic diagnostics
and
prognostic interventions for treating
this disease
and this whole idea is the reason why
i'm taking undertaking this project
so before describing my hypothesis i
will just
describe my data set so i'm using uh for
this particular project i'm using the
data from patient cohort tcga
so the cancer genome atlas i'm using
their esophageal carcinoma dataset
so this data set actually consists of
198 samples
so like 185 are tumor samples and rest
are the normal samples
so here i would like to highlight these
normal samples are nothing but
uh the existing tissue uh to the
tumors and i've retrieved them from the
tcga database fireballs
so talking about the hypothesis uh so uh
through this uh research project i'll be
uh
working on two major objectives so my
first objective would be
uh to know more about the gene
expressions
associated with outcomes and patient so
uh luckily i'm then uh provided with a
ton of uh metadata so for this
particular
for carrying out this particular
objective i'm actually looking at the
vital status
since it is a patient cohort so i am
provided with
uh the patient status
so whether the patient is decreased or
whether the patient is alive
and using that i will be looking at gene
signatures or precisely biomarkers
associated with a prognosis of the
disease
and my second objective would be to know
more about the gene signatures
involved in cancer progression so for
that i'll be
actually uh comparing the late stage
esophageal carcinoma with the early
stage esophageal carcinoma
so here is the analysis plan for
carrying out my objective one
so i started by preparing my data set so
i started by matching the metadata with
the expression data
uh then i performed the differential
gene expression so i categorized my
data into two groups they decreased
versus realize
so as a result of that i got 70
differentially expressed genes
uh with a p with a b adjusted value of
less than
0.05 and log value of less than
less than oh sorry negative or uh
positive 1.5 log full change
so uh just to uh dive deeper into
prognosis
i've actually plotted the
keplin meyer plot so in this slide there
are actually
two figures so first i'd like to
describe the box plot on the right
so uh the box plot is about the
expression of gene md
f1c so this gene is one of the 70 genes
which i have found
by my differential gene expression
analysis
so uh it is clearly evident that the
1c gene was downregulated in uh
decreased
group when compared with their liver and
based on that i have
actually plotted a kepler in my ear plot
so
uh talking about the keplin know if not
it's basically a non-parametric test
uh used to estimate the survival
function and uh this
base uh so this statistical analysis is
uh
usually done uh for knowing the
uh survival analysis for doing the
survival analysis
and to simplify it i have divided for
sake of explaining i have divided into
two parts
so first is your survival curve and
second is a log bank test
so talking about the survival curve the
survival curve
actually represents the survival
probability over time
so uh talking about this uh graph so
there are actually two groups again uh
the low md
f1c group and the high once you go
so talking about the survival curve uh
of the low mdf uh f1c group it is
clearly evident that uh
it is uh you know dropping uh
significantly over time uh while the
high uh if mdf one c group uh
in in case of high nbf one single fiddle
are not the case
so uh but just looking at the curves we
cannot
say anything confidently and then the
log rank test comes into play
so the log ram test is actually a
hypothesis test
um so this actually works by setting up
a null hypothesis
that there is no difference between the
survival function of the two groups
and in this case uh there is no
difference in survival function of high
expression in the f1 0
and the low expression md md f1 0
so the result of this uh log rank p test
was 0.033
which is a less than 0.05 and as a
result we
just you know reject our null hypothesis
and we can
confidently say that the difference
between there is a difference between
the survival function of
these two groups
so based on this uh uh analysis
uh i've actually modified my analysis
plan
so i'll be actually uh taking help of
this uh
so i'll be actually performing a
supervised machine learning
uh random forest so uh during my uh
during time i was
learning doing the transfer comics
module i launched upon this
algorithm and i still remember the
special feature about it
uh that was the feature selection so
feature selection
uh is a unique uh um it's a property of
uh not a property but it's a
criteria for for distinguishing
our two groups so these uh so like
first we i proceeded by
dividing my data into train data and
test data
so the uh the algorithm will
work on uh you know will help me in
finding the
uh those gene expressions which
makes the difference between the alive
and the decreased group
and i'll be uh presenting my progress
next week thank you
just a question there drew how many
groups are you going to
use for your classes
how many classes do you have uh i said
only two
yeah so typically
in classification when it's just two
you know it's very similar to
differential gene expression
right you're looking for genes that are
differentially expressed but
differential gene expression
shows you all of the genes and
classification is tries to limit the
number of genes so it
tries to select only the top features
that contribute to
accuracy and decrease in accuracy and
precision
so if you have only two groups
i don't personally see the reason
why you would go for classification as
your main method
i mean you can use it maybe downstream
but i would try to go back to your
original plan
and look a little bit closer at the
metadata that you mentioned that you
have a lot of data metadata about this
right
and think about you know machine
learning the major challenge that it
addresses
is the high variability in the
gene expression itself because when
you do you know let's find all the
differentially expressed genes like kind
of what we saw in the previous project
presentation
you see actually a lot of variation in
the pca
it's not a straightforward pca there are
some outliers there are some
uh you know groups that are closer or
farther away from
each other and that's where machine
learning is the best
use for it it looks for variation that
is not straightforward
that is not clear the pattern is a
little bit more complex
and that's why you can combine
then this kind of feature selection
with clustering clustering not of
samples but of genes
to kind of see whether you have this
you know coexpression of different sets
of genes
so i think the overall kind of design is
there you've got the major pieces of the
puzzle
but i would refine some of these steps
in the way that you prepare the data
okay so
okay so i'll uh i'll look into it and
i'll be uh presenting my results in the
next video
okay so thank you i have also some
points
so i mean i think uh
especially for the machine learning when
i was talking about the tumor space
classification because we have four
stages remember
so yeah so at that point of time i asked
you maybe you can uh
apply supervised machine learning
because for the tumor stage
classification because we have four
classes then
after identifying some important change
then we may be we can cluster uh early
stage one in space two samples as early
and stage three and stage four as late
stage samples
so for that purposes i mean you can
apply supervised machine learning
particularly when you have like
already four tumor stages okay so
another thing that i just want to add
can you go back to your
uh this kaplan-mir plot
so what i was looking at like you have
total samples
uh if i do remember nearly 180 but if i
am saying looking at this
you have high risk and the low risk
samples only 46 and 46
so whether there is no survival
information is available for rest of the
samples or what is this
and another thing uh like you are
talking about low
md uh fic value so are you taking
specific only one gene
right why you have taken only one gene
so i mean especially captain this the
overall survival analysis
you know survival analysis is
specifically helpful once you have
already identified some important genes
under some conditions for example you
have
for example you are trying to identify
early or the late stage samples and you
have
identified these are the important
change so then you can go for this type
of analysis maybe they are
playing important role in the prognosis
so why are you looking at one change so
i
am my first question was about that and
the major question about these groups
because i just want to know like whether
you don't have the survival information
regarding all the samples or exactly
what was the
why it is like 46 and 46 it's just
like 92 total 92 samples
okay mom so um i have plotted this using
a tool called gpr
so that also uses the same pcga data as
i'm using
so uh i guess the uh the probable reason
would be
on the non-availability of that uh
you have to explore that i mean whenever
you're using a particular tool you must
understand that
uh because you uh you should analyze
like totals you have total samples
this much so why you are getting only
these some groups right
and in fact this is again a significant
when you are actually interpreting these
results you are saying like
this is not a significant or something
but because you have already p-value
significant but apart from that you are
also get the hr value that is
hazard ratio so you also got that
value so that will uh let you know
whether it is actually
uh you know good prognostic factors or
the bad prognostic factor depending upon
whether it's positive hr value or
negative hr value
so that is what i think that would be
after you have already analyzed and then
you must go for the prognostic analysis
i think not it should not be your first
part i mean then
when you are actually uh doing the
analysis and identifying some important
change maybe between early or the late
stage
then maybe you can do this analysis for
those genes
uh okay yeah okay
okay so i'll be uh working on the points
on i'll be uh sharing my progress
yeah apart before even that at least i
mean go for the pca analysis at least
that will help you to understand whether
these classes is able to differentiate
not so then we are identifying some
important genes
that may be able to differentiate these
early or the late space samples
yeah okay
okay thank you so much through for
sharing your research with us
now i would want a penile to share
his research progress over to ukrainian
okay thank you just a minute let me
share my
my screen
uh we can see our screen now thank you
all right hello hello to everyone my
name is uh
spiniel uh
i am presently in china but i am a
tanzanian by nationality
uh i am doing phd here
at shuja america university in china and
my research interest
is neurodegenerative diseases
particularly we
are into parkinson's disease and
glioblastoma
that is what our lab deals with
so for the sake of this presentation uh
for the sake of the this research
fellowship
i'll be i'll be talking about
parkinson's disease and for this case
i've come with that topic which is the
never
novel biomarkers of levodopa induced
dyskinesia
in parkinson's disease a potential
target
for anti-dyskinetic therapy development
so pd is actually the second
most common neurogenic disease that
affects
two to three percent of the old
population
and it's estimated that this might
increase in
the future so basically uh what
it is observed in clinics
is some symptoms and the four
commonest ones are rigidity the tremors
rigidity the tremors and
bradykinesia and
of course it started with parkinson
himself
near 1817 and
what is actually the pathophysiology of
it is uh
is the laws of dopamine in in
some nuclei that are responsible
to to produce uh dopamine
and we have some nuclear in the brain
and uh
for the sake of this presentation it's
good for me to highlight
because that is the metadata talks about
so we have this new clay over here we
call it
striatum and we have global spallidas
and substantia negra so
there is two pathways that are involved
in
uh in in this kinesia
or movement regulation there are two
pathways because i'm talking about the
two pathways because the metadata i have
is talking about the
uh it's about the uh those two pathway
so we have one pathway here we just
start from thread
these two nuclei to this point this is
called stratum
pallidus and here we have striatum
uh negro so striatum negro is a direct
pathway and striatum body that is
indirect pathway so direct pathway in a
nutshell activate the movement
and indirect pathway stop the movement
so if you have loss of dopamine
and these two i mean this all these
nucleus that are
responsible to produce uh dopamine
definitely the mortar system
will be affected so at the end of the
day
the person will present with abnormal
abnormal
movements so in a provision of
integrated treatment for patients with
this disorder
they discover dopamine as a
neurotransmitter and their brain
and deficiency in pd
has been i mean and
leveled over as therapy has been the
major
revolutionary event but the main problem
of leverage
was what we call it dyskinesia so
it is uh reported that overuse i mean
uh chronic use uh
or how high or high dose of levodopa use
it will definitely cause a dyskinesia
and and uh
this is how this is how the dyskinesia
the kinetic patients will
looking like uh abnormal movement that
can affect the lower limbs or even the
the
the upper limbs so
the development of the new therapeutic
interventions
to medicate uh to media mitigate the
risk of dyskinesia and pd
it does a high priority so to
uncover this we have performed a
bioinformatics analysis of microarray
data
a data set gsc 55096
from a jio database to identify
differential express genes
using a lima package gene ontology and
kg
and later also talk about the
protein i mean protein protein
interaction
will be used to to describe
those differential express express genes
so just in nutshell
this metadata metadata contains 77
samples and the it has got the two
pathway direct pathway and indirect
pathway as i mentioned earlier
and uh this direct pathway the
uh and these are the model it's the
model
it's a model of uh of a direct pathway
and a mode of indirect pathway this
model they are treated with
parkinson's disease toxin this is a
toxic for pakistan disease
under control as well similarly to
indirect pathway
so in parkinson's disease model laser
later you know they they they treated
with chronic high level dopa chronic
glow level
and saline the similarity to indirect
pathway performed for only parkinson's
disease they treated with
chronic high level rover chronic low
level dopa
and chronic saline so
we we have discovered that
chronic high level dopamine is a chronic
low level of phenomena
level treatment reveals no significant
molecular changes on indirect pathway
but rather on direct pathway so we uh
we checked uh so what we we found in
chronic it was a chronic hive as chronic
law
on indirect pathway actually with uh
um there was no much uh separation of
these
uh two two uh two dosage
we were talking about chronic low and
chronic high
levodopa and uh with volcano plot
we will not get more uh
up regulated neither down regulated
genes
in this uh indirect pathway this could
indicate that
the this indirect pathway the molecular
changes
on this indirect pathway are not as much
as we
as much as it is in in direct pathway so
the only genes that the only gene that
we
actually found is one one
one gene and this is is higher
in low level compared to uh chronic high
level over
treatment so in
a direct pathway we found that there is
uh
uh a clear clear difference
between the high dose and the low dose
of levodopa
uh in umab and with a number of
upregulated and down regulated genes
actually up
on 1987 afrogleta genes 80 27
down regulated genes were observed in uh
in this direct pathway so we this is
just
uh to represent a number of of
genes that and how the looks like
in these two parts in these two uh
dosage and
chronic high and chronic law and for
example this gene
uh it is higher in chronic
chronic high level than than
in in low and chronic low uh levodopa
so we we we actually
took 20 uh upregulated genes
and so as to visualize their molecular
biological
and cellular and the pathway
and for molecular for example we found
that
most of those genes they are involved in
binding
uh yeah in in binding and for
biological processes most of those genes
are involved
in cellular process processes
and and metabolic processes
and similarly to cellular component we
found that most of the
most of the genes were involved in
cellular anatomical entity
and for the pathway most of the
uh the uh most of the
involved pathway in those upper
regulated genes
is tgf beta signaling pathway
so now if one is talking about to
mitigate or to attenuate the
dyskinesia we thought of using the
upregulated genes
uh if one is think of or think about the
drug discovered to me or
to attenuate the uh that is dyskinesia
we used uh the we checked on the
upregulated genes
and uh for this case we used the
direct pathway because the direct
pathway seemed to have
um more and
clear separation of the doors
then this is i mean the high dose loados
and
the control which was saline and
we found 1449
genes that were intersecting between
those
these three groups and
we checked on the
the volcano plot and
we found this is how the uh volcano
blood looks for
chronic low levels of saline and uh
chronic high level dopa versus
uh chronic chlor levodopa and uh this is
for chronic high levels
chronic style and southern was just a
control group so
we took again top 20
upregulated genes and most of the genes
most of these are
again they are very important because we
also deal on
these genes in some aspects for example
and you are nur 483 this is a
transcription factor and it was for deal
with this
gene in our lab and most of these are
probability genes
are are involved in binding and most of
them are transcription factors
but we checked on
[Music]
jio i mean uh g o part g o
and k e g and we
found that most of these genes are also
are involved in binding
and for biological processes most of
them are
they are similar to the rest of the
other genes that we checked earlier
for example in biological processes most
of them are involved
in biological regulation cellular
processes
and and metabolic processes
so for the cellular component most of
you know also import that they are
involved in cellular anatomical
entity and for the pathway
most of those after religions are
involved
in cckr signaling
map so and uh for the
for the protein class uh we
found that most of these uh those genes
they are involved in gene specific
transcription
transcriptional regulator they are a
gene transcription i mean gene specific
transcriptional regulator so
this is what uh we have
we will do next because at the end of
the day we have to validate those genes
and perhaps if it can later be used
as a treat for treatment
perhaps maybe to
use inhibitor of these genes in order to
regulate or mitigate the
this kinetic movement that are appearing
to
this parkinson's disease models or
humans later
so we have selected a number of genes
according to
according to the uh log change
and uh they are cheaters
i mean i mean uh trt i mean i just
adjusted the p value and their log
change and
these are the genes that we are hoping
to validate
and what we have to do is to make the
packaging of this model
we we are making those models over here
it's not a
big problem and we'll later do the
behavioral test of those models and
waste and bloating again we have to
uh uh during confirmation of these
things we have to do
qpcr western blotting and immunohisto
install
chemistry thank you this is what i plan
to share for today thank you
thank you i think it's a very
interesting project i must say that i
have
quite a number of questions about how um
you kind of started your presentation
today and uh
you know what is the plan overall so i
wonder if we can schedule a separate
meeting
um maybe and dr harpreet can help us
coordinate because you know today's
session
we already have a pretty long session
already uh but but i would love to learn
a little bit more about
you know the data set and the different
treatment
you know objectives that you have so um
thanks for the presentation though sure
sure thank you very much
thank you so much pineal uh so we have a
lot many new research fellows from amity
and
punjab university as well and they have
introduced themselves to uh to our
mentors so i won't be
uh asking them to introduce again but we
have asha today
so asha can you please introduce
yourself she's a phd fellow
i request you to please keep an
introduction short because we're running
uh
out of uh time and we will then schedule
a meeting separately with you and
take your research and trust there then
over to you asha
hello everybody myself
myself from computer science background
my
and i'm in the first year i like to do
phd in like deep
try to predict a deep learning to
prepare a deep learning system
uh what you say to propose an algorithm
for transcriptomic i use by making use
of the transomic analysis of ovarian
cancer
that is prediction system
for the biomarkers of ovarian cancer
linking with precision mixing
thank you so much asha so for all the
research fellows here we
keep on having trainings monthly
trainings on different sorts of topics
so we have this training coming up on
machine learning for biomedical drug
discovery
and then we have chem information
biomedical drug discovery
and all those who are a part of a
research fellowship program they would
get the access to be a part of the
trainings as well
so i would be sharing the details with
you and then you can join the training
too
and also you can be a part of our
ongoing training
i keep on sharing the links with you
already so
it's like those who are interested in
different sorts of research areas they
can pick up whatever training they would
want to go ahead
with right and now i would uh want
uh sabita to introduce herself uh
herself over to you
thank you
[Music]
hello everyone my name is from nepal
i have graduated with a btech and
biotechnology degree from
provencal university nepal so currently
i'm working at different labs in nepal
i'm
working as a plant tissue culturist at
private biotech company
and i am also working at a
center for analytical chemistry at
kashmir institute of applied science
they are
looking at the prevalence of low quality
drugs in nepal
so the reason why i joined this research
fellowship
program is as you know biotechnological
developments
are increasingly dependent on the
extensive use of
data generated by high throughput
instrumentation
so through this program i believe to
learn from experts about data
integration
exploitation and exploration so that i
can
implement them in different
biotechnological areas
thank you thank you so much
and now i would like to tell you all
something so we have had a lot of
enrollments in the research
fellows uh ship program so we are
planning to make up batches of these
research fellows and then we would
uh take your progress there so all the
amity students
the university students and other
students as well
we we could not get to your progress but
yes we have gone through the document
which you
filled out so those who have filled out
their weekly research fellowship
uh program form good and those who have
not
please fill it out we would want to know
where you are in your weekly progress
right
and uh next week when we meet
i would want other research fellows to
please prepare two three slides
and share where they are in this program
right now
and what is their progress so say if you
have completed transcriptomics uh
part like the course transcriptomics
part one two
three then please share what you learned
in those particular courses
and then we can take your queries as
well
and those who have completed the courses
then basel out the
research proposal for and then we will
discuss what your research proposal
uh should be and uh what your
modifications in the proposal have to be
right and now i would want to hand over
to dr harpreet if she wants to say
something over
to your doctor thank you
so i just want to uh i mean inform
everyone please
whenever you have one to one one one to
one meeting before that you must fill
that progress
form that is like compulsory for
everyone
whether you are completing courses or
whether you're completing project or
even if you have done something so you
have to
uh fill that form and then every monday
we used to share that
form with you and uh please fill that
form on monday itself so that we can
look into like
with whom we need a one-to-one meeting
so
that's that's it now and that's
important that is like compulsory for
everyone
it's not like uh your choice and uh then
only after
i i got the response from there and then
we are going to schedule
one one-on-one meeting yeah so
thank you everyone for presenting your
work
and uh i'm looking forward from others
who are just starting the courses so
that you
once you're able to complete
thank you thank you so much dr harpreet
and
at last i would want you all to also
accept my invitation of the
slack channel because it's really very
easy to communicate things directly
there
right and those who have not received
the link yet i'll share with them once
again
and then you can proceed further thank
you so much everyone for being a part of
a research fellowship meeting today
and if you have any any doubt so we had
a number of participants who are going
to enroll themselves for the program
if you have any doubts then please mail
me at marketing at the day pine dot bio
and i'll be there to assist you with
your uh enrollment
thank you so much everyone have a great
day